un antiguo buque insignia de la marina
francesa ahora ya será aquí en el fondo
del Océano Atlántico las autoridades
brasileñas hundieron el Antiguo
portaaviones Fox que llevaba meses en el
mar a 300 kilómetros de la costa
brasileña lleno de asbesto pintura y
otros residuos tóxicos se considera una
bomba ecológica múltiples ongs han
considerado su hundimiento como un
crimen medioambiental por su tamaño 266
metros Y su peso 30,000 toneladas su
reciclaje era impensable según el
Ministerio de defensa brasileño en vista
de los riesgos que significa el remolque
y debido al deterioro del casco la única
solución es abandonarlo hundiéndolo de
forma controlada
el portaaviones fue comprado por Brasil
en el 2000 pero el país decidió
rápidamente deshacerse de él debido a su
obsolencia construido a finales de los
50 El Fox rebotizado Sao Paulo estuvo al
servicio de la marina francesa durante
37 años
participó entre otras en pruebas
nucleares en el Pacífico y en
operaciones en la antigua slavia entre
1993 y 1999